josephine baker no solo fue esta vez
negra que bailaba con el cinturón de
bananas que conoce todo el mundo sino
que también fue una mujer múltiple una
resistente ella se enroló con la
resistencia francesa durante la segunda
guerra mundial para hacer frente a la
ocupación nazi e incluso muchas veces
poniendo en riesgo su vida también fue
una mujer que luchó por los derechos
civiles de los negros en eeuu y
participó recordemos en esta marcha
histórica en 1963 en washington junto a
martin luther king cuando hizo ese
famoso discurso de él tengo un sueño
ihab actriz y también fue una mujer muy
comprometida por la libertad una mujer
emancipada dice él al palacio del elíseo
que supo emanciparse primero de la
discriminación que vivía en eeuu y que
luego ayudó a la emancipación de francia
durante la segunda guerra mundial y por
eso justamente el palacio del icio
mediambiente homenaje por eso francia le
rinde homenaje recordemos en su castillo
en el sur de francia ella adoptó 12
niños de distintas porque tenía una idea
de fraternidad universal y así bautizó
su hogar la villa de la fraternidad
universal para demostrar que niños que
personas de distintas razas de distintos
orígenes e incluso de distintas
religiones podían vivir juntos ella
representa perfecto los ideales de la
república francesa dicen desde el
palacio del elíseo sobre todo el deseo
de libertad y de justicia a santiago